what are the ratings mean what do you
want them to me
[Applause]
[Music]
folks who have been watching my channel
for a while might remember the last time
I talked about the ratings on Doctor Who
I didn't go back and re-watch it I can't
remember if I said I would never talk
about them again I think I might've yeah
I'm gonna talk about them although
probably not in the way a lot of people
are talking about them so ratings or box
office for movies is so often seems to
dominate the conversations and it's
something that I only ever find vaguely
academically interesting usually box
office more so than ratings cuz I
understand movies and how movies make a
good return of investment a lot better
than I do television that's that's just
my knowledge base so people I've never
understood the obsession with ratings
for episodes for a series for a season
mile the only degree to which I care
about ratings for Doctor Who or anything
is is it gonna get renewed for another
year that's it other than that I don't
care but man are some folks obsessed
with the ratings especially this year so
let's cover a couple of broad things
ratings this year overall for Doctor Who
series 12 have not been great they'd
been some of the lowest and actually by
the time it's all done and we truly get
accurate numbers possibly the lowest
average viewer rating for the show
overall in terms of its original airings
in the UK now that might seem overly
specific but that's gonna be
part of part of what I'm getting at with
all this but in any case that's a fact
those are the numbers but here's the
thing there's a difference between
seeing the numbers and then starting to
dictate what those numbers mean and
that's where things get real ugly real
quick and I just kind of feel the need
to point out that so many of the people
right now pointy up the ratings for
series 12 insisting that it's a sign
that the fans have abandoned the show
and nobody likes it and it is
objectively bad were the exact same
people who were saying in series 11 the
fact that it had the highest ratings
boost that the show had had in years
have was not a sign that people liked it
or it or was actually any good quality
so again what people want the ratings to
mean will change depending on the answer
they already have in their head because
the thing about numbers somebody will
tell you numbers don't lie
well no but numbers themselves also they
have a value but that's not the same as
having a meaning so what do I mean by
that well to make the comparison to you
know film or things like that when you
say something is number one at the box
office what that actually translates to
is gonna be different depending on when
it was released something that was
number one at the box box office
released in February probably didn't
pull in the kind of money that whatever
was number one of the box office in June
did just because one seasons busier than
another but it's a question of what
numbers you look at because you could
look at the raw box office of something
that was a hit in February and something
that was hit in June and just look at
the box office numbers and go oh this
must be better cuz it made more money or
you could look at the fact that they
were both number one in the box
oh they must be completely even and
completely equal so whatever people
start talking about ratings I notice how
specific people can get about what
numbers they're looking at because
that's the other thing there isn't one
set of numbers there isn't one set of
ratings and actually before I get too
far into this let me jump to the end
spoilers I'm not gonna tell you honestly
what the ratings mean my point in this
video is to explain to you that the
ratings and what they mean is highly
subjective and highly prejudicial
depending on whoever the heck is talking
so if you're actually holding on for me
to say at the end and here's what they
really mean I'm not gonna do that
because my point is they don't really
mean anything they might mean any number
of things
so anyways coming back so there are all
kinds of ratings
there's the overnight ratings which
tends to be what most at least the
people who I keep popping up in my radar
seem to go on about and there's a debate
as to how much value the overnight
ratings even have at this point
considering that ever-increasing number
of people are watching it on streaming
or on things that some equivalent of DVR
the next day so should we even be
measuring overnights the same then
there's like then the consolidated
numbers from over several days meeting
people who record it and then watch it a
little bit later so there's that
do we count its overseas numbers you
know how it did want to aired in this
territory that territory do we only look
at the British numbers there's a lot of
things you can do to finagle and if you
want to look at something other than the
raw ratings you could look at the
ranking for where it came in the night
was it number one in the night what was
it number five if you really want to
make it look bad you could have you
could say what it looked like for the
week because Doctor Who if you if you go
by I have some notes on this if you go
by what any given episode looked like
for the week it can look really bad I
didn't I didn't go through everything on
every episode of the entire thing but as
an example so the finale for series 11
the Battle of Ron score of kolos I think
I finally said it right so that was
number four in the overnight ranking so
number four for the day when it aired
for the week overall though it was
number 21 because there was stuff being
aired at other points of the week that
just was way more popular than doctor
who was but somebody could very easily
pick that where it landed in the week
number two make it look worse that
number isn't a lie but you can always
strip out the context to make the
numbers mean what you want them to mean
so it is objectively true the ratings
are down for series 12 however anyone
who immediately makes the leap of it's
because the show sucks well hold on we
are right now dealing with a series that
premiered in January witch doctor who
hasn't done before so it's airing at a
time when it hasn't really aired
previously it is coming off basically a
year of silence that's not good for any
show and that has damaged Doctor Who
before
series 10 was the previous worst rated
series and that one was also coming off
a pretty lengthy stretch of no regular
episodes because between series 9 we had
two specials before we got series 10 and
then nothing like we went along so all
the time before we got series 10 and was
that the reason series 10 didn't do well
it probably was a factor so there's that
the marketing push was way softer first
series 12 than it was for series 11 I
don't know if they thought that they
could just coast come in there was
obviously a very big marketing push for
series 11 they
reason to do a big push there was
something big to talk about new doctor
hey free press all the stuff see where
series 12 is just another season of
television so there's all of these
things that may be contributing factors
for why this series hasn't done as well
and pretty much none of them are because
our sharks if you think it sucks that's
fine but the reasons the ratings are
down it cannot be one thing it can't
life is not that simple it would be
wonderful if it was that way that would
just make everything easy wouldn't it
but life is not that simple life is
complicated and these numbers are
affected by a lot more than any one
single thing now something else I'm
gonna bring up and the people who are
wishing for the show to get cancelled
which can I so just say I don't get that
at all like look if the show's not for
you anymore and you want to and you make
the decision to stop watching that's
fine I can respect that if you are going
to hope that the show again becomes
something that you enjoy great totally
get that but actively hoping for its
cancellation I don't understand that you
people need to like take some cues from
like the comic book fandom when I was
growing up like 80s 90s not to say that
the comic books were good a lot of them
weren't but like I don't remember
anybody even when they were reading
comics that they love that when
directions they didn't like going I hope
the book gets cancelled no they were
going I hope they replaced the writer I
hope they bring it back to what I like
but you don't hope for it to be canceled
because if it cancelled maybe never
because I'm tangent thing anyways the
other thing is is that the overnight
numbers don't really matter anymore not
just for the reason that I mentioned
before which is a lot of people do
streaming on all this other stuff Doctor
Who is an international show
the BBC partners with a lot of
international territories and channels
and licensees for this thing big HBO max
just did a major partnership with BBC
and dr. who was the crown jewel of that
so while I'm sure the BBC would like the
ratings in the UK to be better than what
series 12 was and I'm not gonna pretend
the series 12 ratings were great they
weren't but that's not the requirement
for this to be worth than keeping around
I I forget who it was I and I apologize
but somebody at the BBC effectively said
as much recently because they were asked
about the radio show but they said no we
have a strong alliance with our various
partners who we helped who helped to
make doctor who would Liz he cited the
partners like HBO like all these other
territories all these other channels
where Doctor Who also airs it doesn't
depend entirely on just the UK overnight
or daily or weekly numbers so I suppose
if anything I'm hoping the takeaway is
stop watching the ratings like just just
stop you're gonna drive yourself crazy
because if you're going to them looking
for an objective truth you're not gonna
find it the only truth that's there is
whatever you project on to it and if you
are able to not project one on to it
then you are just gonna keep finding
trying to find more and more and more
more contacts to find out the actual
truth and you're gonna drive yourself
nuts because you have to look at so many
things at the marketing what is it
airing against that's something I didn't
even get into some of doctor whose
lowest rate its lowest lowest rated
nights were when it had to compete with
really big things like find like finales
on competition shows and things like
that there are factors well beyond
is the fandom happy there are so many
reasons that the numbers go up or the
numbers go down and is the fandom happy
is one of them but it's not the only one
it's not even close there are dozens of
factors dozens of reasons for why these
numbers go up or go down so please stop
quoting the ratings like they prove
anything about the quality of the show
or the stance of the fandom you want to
know what I put a lot more stock in as
far as reception I had some really big
issues with the last episode of series
12 of the timeless children III had to
put I had to put that review in my
angriest rants playlist but I also saw a
lot of people in the comments saying
they really liked it so I wasn't going
by completely anecdotal I put up a poll
and asked hey what do you think of it
loved it like it mixed didn't like it
hate it most people ranged from mixed to
love it didn't like it and hate it was
the minority even combined those two
still severe minority so if you're
looking at tumbling ratings going this
means everyone hates it doesn't they're
just their numbers without meaning until
you project a meaning onto it and if you
come into it having decided what they
already mean then that's all they're
gonna mean to you I was gonna say
ratings this time I'm done talking about
them by autumn I'm not gonna promise
that I hope I'm done talking about them
because I basically just spent what like
18 minutes talking about why you
shouldn't even bother
paying attention to them or however long
I've been talking anyway that's my
ramble on the ratings whatever your
thoughts are on what I've said drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it be polite cuz when I want
to talk about the ratings people that
got mad at me last time suspect they
will again but be polite I am NOT I'm
not shy about banning people who are
harassing jerks not harassing jerks but
they are harassing jerk
yeah whatever I'm going to bed
look that's it for this one like
subscribe share this around support me
on my patreon that would be lovely it's
my birthday this month I got an Amazon
wishlist down there as well supporting
on the patient I would actually be a
nicer present but you know either ones
very nice but you don't have to do any
bit end of the day you're the council
I'm running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]